La pregunta es debería quedarse o irse
mientras el presidente erdogan Hace
campaña un número récord de turcos
siguen indecisos sobre Sí prorrogar el
mandato de dos décadas del actual
presidente
antes era partidario del akp pero ya no
pienso votarles
lleva mucho tiempo en la oposición y
todavía no ha hecho ninguna promesa
tranquilizadora y convincente
el líder de la oposición que mal
quilishrollo intuye que esta es su mejor
oportunidad para desbancar a erdogan ya
que se espera que el 14 de mayo voten
por primera vez más de 6 millones de
personas erdogan es el único gobernante
que han conocido pero muchos Jóvenes
turcos piensan que es hora de un cambio
con muchos jóvenes me sentía político
sin embargo las promesas del partido
popular republicano y de atraen creo que
se pueden restaurar los derechos y
restablecer la justicia
un número creciente de ciudadanos culpa
erdogan por la creciente inflación y la
erosión del poder adquisitivo de los
turcos especialmente en la región
azotada por dos terremotos en febrero
donde erdogan también ha sido criticado
por la mala gestión de las operaciones
de búsqueda y rescate
los tomates cuestan 30 libras el kilo y
un apartamento hasta 8000 y se supone
que tenemos que ir a votar
Los partidarios de erdogan dicen que
kilish no sería capaz de arreglar la
economía también como la actual
presidente también son escépticos sobre
la solidez de su alianza opositora de
seis partidos Mientras tanto la
oposición turca se queja de la
imparcialidad de la votación y de su
seguridad después de que uno de sus
mítines fuera interrumpido El domingo
cuando se lanzaron piedras contra el
alcalde de Estambul en uno de los
bastiones de erdogan